those were world famous writers Maureen
Johnson and a la carte by the way the
Brotherhood 2 website looks awesome it's
6:30 in the morning I'm extremely tired
and I have a long day of writing ahead
of me so we're going to make this quick
and we're gonna do it school style first
period math I would like to briefly
explain the 7042 mishap what happened
was that I incorrectly believed and
indeed have always believed that each
minute contains 100 seconds were that to
be true there would be 75 second
segments in each 3 minute and 30 second
period it turns out and this is
extraordinarily difficult news for me to
accept that each minute only contains 60
seconds and therefore there's only 42 5
second segments in each 3 minute and 30
second period this is a tragedy not only
for the American minute but also for me
personally it makes the fact that the
first draft of my new novel is doing
eight thousand six hundred and forty
minutes forty percent more terrifying
second period
it's supposed to be history but your
teachers lazy and all you ever do is
watch TV shows he taped Hank I feel like
one of my duties to you as the brother
who does on a working television is to
keep you informed periodically about
what's going on in the world of
entertainment Paula Abdul has a drug
problem Ivanka Trump isn't probably
attractive period three physical
education Hank the Bears are just one
game away from the Super Bowl and if I
have my way I will be filming
Brotherhood 2.0 from the Super Bowl
fourth period English Hank your battle
of the books inspired me to have my own
battle of the books because I thought
that your battle of the books was
hilarious and then I thought maybe my
battle look could be kind of like a pale
imitation and people would laugh and say
well it's good it's not as funny as
Hanks and you know that's pretty much my
goal with this thing round one the
American edition of Looking for Alaska
versus the Dutch edition of Looking for
Alaska hey how's it going okay how are
you hey why don't you have an accent I
don't I don't do accents it
ha oh wait no it's the Danish edition of
Looking for Alaska and the British
edition waiter the British on the
American signs are they on the Dutch
sides
oh my god they're for Europe not America
it wasn't until I started editing that
that I realized oh my god I am such a
loser I can't even bring myself to show
you the Hemingway vs. Faulkner one it's
even more embarrassing announcements
hang could you possibly mail me some of
the misprinted eco geek business cards
just like five of them Thanks
you can get my address from mom and dad
also can we agree to have our happy
dance compilation video done around the
end of February ok ok ok big day big day
big day big day a few thousand words two
thousand words two thousand words two
thousand words okay I'm going to go back
to bed